five numbers are in AP whose sum is 25
and the product is 2520 so if one of
these five numbers is minus one by two
we have to find the greatest number
among them so the very first thing is
five numbers are in AP so you have to
assume them symmetrically so uh the
Assumption will be somewhat like this
guys a minus 2D
a minus d
a
a plus d and a plus 2 D so you see over
here that the common difference will be
D only and this is a plus b so we can
use a square minus b square identity so
5 minus 2D and 5 plus 2D now we can
further simplify this thing this will be
five fives are 25 and this is also 5 5
is the 25 so let's further simplify this
is 25 minus 4 d square and this is going
to be 25 minus d square so that is equal
to 5 0 4 over here